[Music]
so here you are with rich insights at
your fingertips you're getting
information that you've never seen
before finding sensitive data in places
you didn't even know data existed
what next what do you do with all this
newfound knowledge
if you've been following along you know
that with automatic dlp gaining
visibility across your entire
organization and keeping sensitive data
secure is now easier than ever if you
haven't seen our previous videos check
out this playlist as we cover some
necessary contextual info
so what data driven actions can you take
to protect your data
well you can investigate the findings
further by running a deep inspection
scan
an inspection scan provides more options
for what to scan and gives individual
findings down to the byte and cell level
think of it as a deep investigation tool
you can create a de-identified copy of
your data based on what auto dlp found
and use those copies in your business
operations instead of the original
tables
this obfuscates the values of pii while
maintaining the raw data
you can delete the problematic table fix
iam permissioning or monitor data use
through dashboards
let's take a look at some scenarios
first scenario we'll talk about a table
found with credit card numbers and a
high free text score
you just started at your new job on the
security team as a data risk analyst and
brought in automatic dlp since you used
it with your previous team
you configure profiling for your
organization and the auto dlp profile
results indicate that a column in a
table is found with a high free text
score and evidence of credit card
numbers and other personally
identifiable information or pii
this means that there may be a column of
unstructured data in your table that has
instances of pii in it
this could be a note or a comment field
where someone typed in a credit card
number instead of in a credit card field
this is an indication of potential risk
and is likely not something you intended
to store
you flag it to your manager and suggest
running a deep scan to investigate
further and pinpoint where the sensitive
data is
it turns out that some customers have
been adding their payment information
into a field that was not designed to
store sensitive data
the notes and comments are very useful
but you don't want the raw pii visible
so you decide to obfuscate pii through
dlp's de-identification service
now your new manager is impressed your
company's data is protected and your
overall data risk is lowered you can
learn more about deep scans and
de-identification with our getting
started with dlp series here our second
scenario is about a table that was found
with sensitive data and shared broadly
after running a scan automatic dlp
identifies a table that contains
hundreds of emails and home addresses
the table was intended to be temporarily
shared with carl on the events team
since he's helping to send out some swag
to customers
turns out instead of being shared
directly with carl this table was made
public and shared across every
department and the entire company and
even partner teams and potentially the
whole
internet
so
now not only does carl and everyone on
the events team have access to this
sensitive information
but it could be publicly exposed outside
of the company
this highly increases the risk of
exposure and possible misuse of
information
now that you've been made aware of this
issue you can remediate it by adjusting
the permissions on this table to remove
public access and add carl directly as
the specific user that should have
access to the data
which is probably what should have been
done in the first place
in addition you can use the insights
from data profiles to closely monitor
your data
for example you might click from the
console dashboard for that table into
cloud logging in order to review any
recent access activity more generally
because of this incident you want to
ensure your data compliance team can
better monitor sensitive data
using the pre-made data studio dashboard
or creating your own puts richer
aggregations of your data at your team's
fingertips and allows you to monitor
your data more easily at a glance
you could review the dashboard in your
daily weekly or bi-weekly team meetings
and see what changes have occurred in
your security posture
you could even have the dashboard
projected on a monitor in your team's
area of the office so changes can easily
be detected by all necessary
participants
automatic dlp is built to minimize the
risk of sensitive data being mishandled
or exposed and help you prevent privacy
security and compliance issues
and now you know how to easily monitor
and protect large amounts of sensitive
data and mitigate data risk
thanks for coming along for the ride to
learn about cloud dip and its new
automatic ga release if you have any
other ideas or stories about how to use
automatic dlp to help protect your
organization's sensitive data
share it with us in the comments and as
always
thanks for watching
[Music]